THE WILL OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO,
JOINING US NOW AUTHOR OF THE
DEEP STATE, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR JASON CHAFFETZ.
THE AUTHOR OF THE RUSSIAN
HOAX FOX NEWS LEGAL ANALYST
GREGG JARRETT AUTHOR OF THE
CASE AGAINST THE DEMOCRATIC
HOUSE IMPEACHING TRUMP
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
DERSHOWITZ.
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZ, I WILL
BEGIN WITH YOU.
IF THIS IS THE CASE ALL OF
THESE OTHER PEOPLE THAT WE
KNOW LIED TO CONGRESS AND IN
THE CASE OF HILLARY, THEY
WERE SUBPOENAED.
SHE DID THE DELETE THEM.
SHE DID ACID WASH THE HARD
DRIVE AND SHE DID BUST UP
DEVICES, WHERE IS HER
PREDAWN RAID AND THE PREDAWN
RAID OF EVERYONE ELSE I
MENTIONED.
>> YOU REMEMBER BRIAN PGA
WAS THE TECH FOR HILLARY
CLINTON I ISSUED A SUBPOENA
AND HE REFUSED TO SHOW UP
FOR CONGRESS.
NOT ONLY WAS THERE A PREDAWN
RAID THEY NEVER ARRESTED AND
PROSECUTED AND NEVER DID
ANYTHING ABOUT HIM.
INSTEAD WHAT YOU HAD WAS
THIS FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE HANDING OUT
IMMUNITY AGREEMENTS SO THEY
GOT THE EASIEST TREATMENT
POSSIBLE.
AT THE SAME TIME, AS YOU
POINT OUT, THERE WERE EMAILS
AND DOCUMENTS, CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION SO HIGHLY
CLASSIFIED EVEN I AS THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE COULD NOT SEE THIS
INFORMATION.
IT WAS OUT IN THE WIND.
TOLD UP TO 300 PEOPLE HAVE
THIS SECURE INFORMATION.
AND A NONCLASSIFIED SETTING.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DID NOTHING.
IT'S THE DUPLICITY.
IT'S THE UNBALANCE.
IT'S THAT LADY JUSTICE
PEEKING UNDER A BLINDFOLD
AND ACTING DIFFERENTLY FOR
THE DEMOCRATS THAN THEY DO
ON REPUBLICANS THAT IS SO
DISGUSTING.
>> Sean: GREG, I WANT IT GET
YOUR THOUGHTS ON.
THIS JASON IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT.
AND, IN FACT, HUMA ABEDIN
AND CHERYL MILLS, TWO OF
HILLARY CLINTON'S TOP AIDS
CLEARLY MADE FALSE AND
MISLEADING STATEMENTS TO THE
FBI.
AND EMAILS PROVE THAT THOSE
WERE FALSE STATEMENTS.
AND JASON DURING A COMMITTEE
HEARING, INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE HEARING CONFRONTED
JAMES COMEY ABOUT IT AND
COMEY SAID, QUOTE, WELL,
THERE IS ALWAYS CONFLICTING
RECOLLECTION OF FACTS.
YOU KNOW, THIS FROM THE SAME
GUY WHO USED NO FACTS, NO
EVIDENCE, TO PROBABLE CAUSE
TO LAUNCH A DILATING AND
IMPROPER AND ILLEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION OF DONALD
TRUMP AND NOW HIS LONG-TIME
FRIEND AND ALLY ROBERT
MUELLER IS PRETTY MUCH DOING
THE SAME.
THESE ARE PROCESS CRIMES.
BUT OUT INDICTMENT OF ROGER
STONE ONLY SHOWS TODAY THAT
MUELLER HAS FAILED TO MEET
HIS MANDATE.
NO ONE HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
A CRIME FOR WHICH MUELLER
WAS APPOINTED.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, PROFESSOR
DERSHOWITZ, YOU TALK ABOUT
THE CRIMINALIZING OF
POLITICAL DIFFERENCES HERE.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE I
MENTIONED AND GREGG JUST
MENTIONED ARE GUILTY OF THE
EXACT SAME THING THAT THEY
CHARGED ROGER STONE WITH.
IF WE'RE GOING TO ARREST ONE
PERSON, IF WE'RE GOING TO
SAY THAT'S JUSTICE.
WHERE IS EQUAL JUSTICE?
WHERE'S EQUAL APPLICATION OF
OUR LAWS?
>> NO, I AGREE.
I THINK WE SHOULDN'T ARREST
ANY OF THEM.
WE SHOULD LET THIS BE FOUGHT
OUT IN THE POLITICAL ARENA.
LOOK, TODAY'S ARREST IS PART
OF A LONG PATTERN BY
MUELLER.
ONLY ARREST PEOPLE FOR
CRIMES THAT OCCUR EVEN AFTER
HE CAME OUT OF OFFICE CRIMES
STEM LATHE YOU HAD
ESSENTIALLY BY THE
INVESTIGATION OR CRIMES THAT
OCCURRED EARLIER BUT HAVE
NOTHING TO DID WITH RUSSIA,
TAX EVASION, BANK FRAUD,
TAXICAB MEDALLIONS OR ONE
CASE WHERE HE INDICTS
RUSSIANS WHO WILL NEVER COME
INTO THIS COUNTRY SHOW
INDICTMENT.
ARRESTING SOMEBODY.
RIGHT.
AND THE USED OF ARRESTING
SOMEBODY LICK TONE THE WAY
THEY ARRESTED HIM IS A CIVIL
LIBERTARIANIAN NIGHTMARE.
UP IN ARMS.
NOW THE GOVERNMENT COP SEWED
HE HAD WEIGH WAS NOT A
FLIGHT RISK OR DANGER AND
THEY ACCEPTED VERY LOW
BAILING AND LET HIM LEAD.
THEY SHOULD HAVE CALLED HIS
BORROW AND PLEASE SHOW UP
TOMORROW.
HE WILL BE AREIGNED.
THAT'S THE WAY WHITE COLLAR
CRIMINALS ARE TWEETED.
WHAT THEY WANT TO DO WITH
STONE IS SQUEEZE HIM THE WAY
THEY SQUEEZED FLYNN AND
MANAFORT AND JUDGE ELLIS WHO
SAID THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED
IN MANAFORT.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN WHAT
MANAFORT CAN GIVE THEM ON
TRUMP.
THEY WANT TO HAVE HIM SING
AND THE FEAR IS THESE PEOPLE
MAY ALSO COMPOSE.
WE KNOW SOME OF THEM
PROBABLY HAVE ALREADY
COMPOSED, MAYBE UP STORIES.
NOW STONE HAS SAID HE WON'T
DO IT.
OF COURSE, MICHAEL COHEN